welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Michael Reid Hurtado the coca-cola
world fund faculty fellow at Yale and
senior lecturer of Latin American
Studies he is a Colombian US journalist
and lawyer with more than 20 years of
experience in the field of Latin
American human rights today we talked
with him about transitional justice in
Colombia welcome Thank You Marilyn it's
great to be here let's start with a bit
of context about what it's like in
Colombia today
well Colombia is a nice little black box
of contradictions it's a middle-income
country of about 48 million people its
GDP is surrounding 378 billion dollars
that's roughly seven thousand five
hundred dollars per capita it has a
booming economy principally now
concentrating on mining and the electric
sector it's institutions are relatively
strong within Latin America it's known
as one of the most stable democracies
now to the other side it's also been a
country that has faced armed conflict on
a perpetual basis and extreme violence
for the period of the ending of the 40s
and 50s we lived at a time when when
it's even known historically as the
violence with a capital v liberals and
conservatives just killed each other
there was a lot of intimate violence a
lot of very expressive and grotesque
violence amongst families and along
those party lines after that time there
was a sharing of power between liberals
and conservatives until finally in the
early 70s we went back to the regular
democratic election since that time
there's been uninterrupted democratic
elections the institution's just get
stronger after a 1991 in Constitution
reform and a new constitution new
institutions came to life that even
though we're in the middle of conflict
that that has
stopped since the 60s we have a
constitutional court that presents
amazing decisions that are heralded as
you know earth breaking and news
breaking throughout the world great
liberal legal tradition very very
sophisticated constitutional rights
balancing tests go on however if you
look at life in Colombia once you get
out of the urban centers once you get
out of ba out of mana gene these are all
cities that bullet dies in eight million
people city managing is more around the
two million per person city Gandhi is
also around that size but cut our mind
guys a little bit smaller we're full of
these middle sized cities or large
cities but once you get out of that you
get to rural Colombia and that's where
the conflict really really hits
polarization of society is is intense
everybody's suspected of being an enemy
and violence is also incredible with
those forty eight million people we can
say that there's about six million
people that have been officially
recognized as victims of the conflict so
as you can tell it's a great
contradiction yes it's it's actually
quite a dichotomy between the urban life
and rural life and I guess my question
would be why do not the people who live
in the rural areas move into the cities
to get away from that well there's been
actual a lot of movement voluntary since
the 1970s and where the country roughly
stood in a balance of believe 40 percent
individuals living in urban life and
sixty percent living in more rural type
like over the decades that has
completely inverted and today we have a
population that seventy percent urban
and thirty percent now that has not all
been voluntary migration in fact that
period of the violence and afterwards
the the ongoing conflict the action by
both illegal armed actors as well as the
armed forces have led to a lot of forced
displacement though there's a lot of
contestation as to the exact numbers we
are in the millions of persons that have
migrated
a result of forced reasons from rural
Colombia to urban life now urban life
isn't that quiet either you can we have
cities that are very much segregated and
set up a long Geographic barrier so
there's a certain part of bullet ah that
is crossed sort of in the north part of
the center from north from the center of
town that is generally considered to be
that type of your regular city in all of
Latin America however once you get
outside of those areas the things get
very complicated you have illegal ways
of controlling every single economic
activity you have all kinds of informal
ways of providing security and again
illegal armed actors drug trafficking
other forms of organized crime also
affect the lives of these individuals so
we also have a lot of intra-city
displacement where people in meta-gene
have to go from one commune to the other
just because they do not get along with
the particular so there would seem to be
an absolute control also in the city by
the state authorities however that seems
to be more an ideal than in practice
unfortunately the situation in the
cities isn't that's great either our
standards of poverty as well there's
been a lot of debates of the changing
numbers but roughly we can say that
there's 30 percent of the people that
are affected by poverty I would say that
it's a lot greater unemployment and sub
employment is also much greater than
recognized officially and people are
just doing their daily their day in
order to survive just to make ends meet
on a daily basis and it's about survival
and it's about survival in a very
vicious very violent and very much led
by enemy and often again that's the
contradiction of Colombia we have laws
for everything we have you know a debate
on the new police code then we have a
debate on a law that resolves the
problems of those people that have been
forcibly displaced at the same time you
have a law that tries to regulate all of
urban action and all of urban life but
just stays in the books law and practice
really doesn't have that great of an
effect so why has the violence been
going on for so long and who is in
control today of Columbia so the control
undoubtedly is one of the state
throughout the nation however there are
prepaid there are places where that
sovereignty gets affected and where in
fact arms groups such as the guerrilla
groups whether it's the four SS Armand
Aleutian areas at Columbia that's the
Armed Forces they're the Revolutionary
Armed Forces of Colombia known as the
photic or the Olin do hold a lot of
territory so that's one dimension and
there there's a discussion of the root
causes of the conflict versus other
types of greed or grievances that might
be present there is another element of
the conflict that though it does not
explain its initiation and and this
source of violence it does explain its
perpetuation and that is thriving
illegal bonanzas and economic bonanza
principally around illicit crops
particularly related to coca and all
that relates to the nautical trafficking
that has been something that has been
present in Colombia since the 80s
separated from the armed conflict but
very quickly weaving into the armed
conflict making it to be very very
stable I think the other reason why the
armed conflict is going on for so long
is that the economy has stabilized
around that conflict so one would expect
that since there's conflict the
economy's doing bad however the
economy's not doing that bad it
continues to grow regularly growth rates
again depending on who you look or
between three point five to five percent
per year that's not bad in a country
that's phasing that type of conflict and
I think the other reason why it's
perpetuated so much is because you can
basically lead your life in Colombia as
a middle class or working class citizen
like nothing was going on outside you go
to work you come back you go to the
malls you go to the movies you have your
experience around the TV you suffer end
lism hours of traffic and in these
cities but it's the normal urban blight
you can ignore what is happening you
could ignore the atrocity there's an
absolute separation and denial with the
atrocity that goes on on a daily basis
in Colombia as a result of the conflict
okay so how does transitional justice
fit in to this situation first let's
talk about what transitional justice is
and then what it actually will mean for
Colombia well the reason why
transitional justice is being discussed
currently in Colombia is principies
we're in a context of a peace
negotiation and that has been a
situation that we haven't seen in quite
a long time especially we've never been
at a point as we are now of really
seeing peace negotiations between the
insurgents and the government advanced
as much as they have been so
transitional justice has come into play
now let's discuss what transitional
justice is transitional justice is
basically shorthand and it's an
unfortunate shorthand but it's just
caught on
everybody talks about transitional
justice without really knowing what it
is and it is shorthand for a series of
processes and measures that promote the
rule of law and justice in times of
transition now that's a mouthful it's a
lot easier to talk about transitional
justice transitional justice is really
not a type of justice it's more a
catchphrase that describes what took
place in the 80s principally in the
context of Latin America and the
transitions from authoritarianism to
democracies or in Eastern Europe as they
were also transitioning out of the
communist regime in both of these places
societies very much pushed for truth
justice and reparations as a way of
dealing with the legacy of violations as
a way of promoting accountability as a
way of promoting justice but also as a
way of looking to the future of making
sure that you were able to turn the page
now in both of those contexts in as much
as you have a very clear successor
regime that can look back and say we
want to get rid of the past the past is
bad all these measures that were
thought of as transitional justice such
as truth Commission's special
prosecutorial initiatives vetting
individuals from public administration
makes sense you're trying to make a
clear break from the past in order to
get to a more promising future and
consolidate this new promise of
democracy so that's where transitional
justice comes from that's where the
expression comes from I think the best
definition that I can provide is more
descriptive and it comes from the UN's
secretary-general report back in 2004
where he says that transitional justice
is basically a shorthand in order to
demonstrate the type of promotion of
justice and promotion of rule of law
through mechanisms and processes
associated with a society that wants to
deal with the past in order to serve
justice further accountability and
achieve reconciliation now those
mechanisms can be of many types and
basically what he does is he lists some
making sure that it is not an exclusive
list but rather one of examples of
things that have popped up such as again
truth Commission's special prosecutorial
initiatives vetting processes
institutional reform and reparations for
victims we have not yet identified all
the tools that are available they're
very much context specific and context
sensitive transitional justice is
largely a social cultural and political
move to press for justice in terms of
transition and that's why we're at this
situation so who actually are the
players overseeing the transitional
justice process I mean I know there's
many different factions there how do
they all work together I mean I would
imagine you wouldn't want some of the
people who are participating of course
so the context right now since it is
about the peace negotiations you have
one discussion that relates to what type
of justice measures will be adopted
after a peace deal is reached and that
presently is a very confidential
an area where both government and
guerilla are discussing about these
measures now as you can imagine both of
these actors have a lot to hide they in
fact have been part of the atrocity they
are they're the ones that are
responsible for the atrocities
perpetrated and they of course want to
probably provide mutual impunity for
each other they have been very good at
voicing the proper words to the public
and saying we're not going to reach
agreements that that implicates mutual
impunity --zz we're not going to give
each other amnesties however in fact
both of them have a huge tendency to try
to adopt a highly politicized sense of
justice a type of Justice that is
devaluated let's say a softer light
justice to get on with with the future
and ignore the past now
the other sectors that come in and that
have been very prevalent in Colombia for
a very long time our grassroots
movements victims groups and human
rights organizations and these
organizations for decades have been
demanding truth justice and reparations
as a human rights movement it
concentrated principally around state
actors basically all the repression that
took place by the military and by the
police throughout the 70s throughout the
80s throughout the 90s and throughout
the armed conflict maybe towards the end
of the 90s and and the first decades of
this century we do start seeing victims
of the guerrilla arise and also demand
truth justice and reparations
I think principally linked to the issue
of kidnapping the guerrilla did have a
policy and a practice of kidnapping
certain individuals even if they say
it's not a policy without a doubt there
was systematic use of kidnapping and
eventual killings by these guerrillas so
that group of victims is also demanding
truth justice and reparations so that's
another very different voice now outside
of those two you also have other sectors
of society that are not interested in
uncovering the past basically B's there
has been links in organizational links
to institutional type violence there is
a lot of illegality in Colombia that if
we start uncovering atrocity we're proud
we gonna get also to get to issues of
corruption and we're going to get to
lengths of very prestigious elite
economic and local elites tied in to the
logic and to the dynamic violence they
too are interested in not having a great
say-so
so we're at a moment of huge tension
it's a political moment where those
wielding the power probably want a soft
sense or a soft type of justice and the
victims are demanding for as much
justice truth and reparations as they
can get so how do you think things will
play out I mean do you think Columbia
does have a chance for peace and you
know what will that mean in terms of
transitional justice how things play out
for Columbia so I do hope that the
negotiation leads to the ending of the
conflict that will be very very
important and as much as it gets rid of
this enemy type logic that has polarized
Columbia it will also get rid of the
insurgency counterinsurgency paradigm
that has led political debates in
Colombia for a very long time as far as
peace is concerned I think by ending the
conflict we're finally out of states
where we started building peace what
that looks like is not about the peace
settlement between guerrillas and the
government building peace will have to
implicate all political forces all
private parties in Colombia at the
different levels so starting with a huge
national pact that is inclusionary that
ratifies again the rules and the
institutions of democracies so that
violence is no longer part of political
life that ratifies again the basic rules
in institutions of economy where we do
get rid of corruption and other forms of
illicit mechanisms of exploiting the
economy in Colombia but then we need to
get to the local level and that is what
does the state look like at the local
level what do the people that have been
abandoned marginalized that have been
mostly affected by conflict want from
the state and what can the state do
there it's a lot easier said than done
it's a lot easier to think of an ideal
total state that will reach everybody
and start providing truth that it will
start providing
health education we're talking about a
country that needs to be developed an
infrastructure and it's electrical
network needs to develop schools and
again all these people that have been
excluded need to be brought in as
citizens so I think we're just beginning
it is hopeful without a doubt but we're
just beginning that process of
understanding that our political
spectrum needs to widen that tolerance
and respect for dissent needs to take
place in such a way that violence isn't
the way to resolve it and that Colombia
needs to incorporate populations that
have been marginalized then we get to
the very uncomfortable situation of how
are we going to deal with our legacy of
atrocity how much truth how much justice
in how much reparations there's a
tendency that says well we need to be
pragmatic and political about it so it's
as much truth and justice as the system
can handle I think that's a bad formula
and I really think that it needs to be
enough truth and justice to really get
to denial and very much face the regime
of atrocity that has taken over all for
all sorts of public and private life in
Colombia these are uncomfortable truths
they will implicate generals that will
implicate very powerful politicians they
will implicate very important cattlemen
for example and this is probably one of
the most trying and most difficult times
there is still some time to go again
we're still at the negotiation phase
there's a lot of spoilers that are that
are taking place but it does seem that
the society as a whole is getting ready
for these very big debates of assuming
that strategic decisions meaning what
what do we want Colombia to look like in
the future is it possible to think of a
Colombia after so many decades of
conflict without the conflict and I
think if society gets involved in these
greater debates about the ends that
we're looking for as a result of the
peace process news might be hopeful in a
couple of years wow that would be
remarkable thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
for more information about professor
Reid Hurtado and his research please
visit our website at yale.edu slash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you